The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN:
Kurosawa's Rashomon
is a particularly
dramatic example
of a film that
understands itself
to have the kind of
claim on its audience
that the greatest art
has always imagined
itself to have on its audience.
So I want to begin by talking
very briefly about what
I call the moment of Rashomon.
There's a bit of
confusion, or at least
chronological confusion, or
inconsistency in the principle
that we end the course with a
film that was made and shown
internationally before
the last two films
that we've seen in our course.
My reasons for that, as I
partly explained in an earlier
lecture, had to
do with my desire
to show a certain
continuity amongst forms
of European cinema and the
link between Jean Renoir,
and the Italian neorealists,
and the French nouvelle vague
is so intimate that
it seemed to me
important to show you that
progression in sequence.
But if we had been going by
strict chronological order,
we would have introduced this
Kurosawa film a bit earlier,
because it was made in 1950.
And in 1951, it won an important
international prize, The Golden
Lion, the highest prize
available at the Venice Film
Festival in 1951.
And this had a seismic effect
on movies around the world.
The dramatic and
powerful subject matter
of Kurosawa's film of
course riveted attention.
But even more than that, the
freedom and imaginative energy
of his stylistic
innovations in the film
had a profound impact on
filmmakers around the world.
And when the film was shown at
Venice in 1951, another effect
it had when it won the prize
was to introduce Japanese cinema
to a wider world.
It was the first significant
Japanese film, Kurosawa,
the first important
Japanese director
to gain a reputation
outside of Japan itself.
In fact, there are many
film buffs, and especially
specialists in
Japanese film, who
are somewhat resentful
of Kurosawa's eminence,
even though no one denies
that he is an eminent
director, because there
are other directors.
The two I've listed under
item 2 in our outline
are the most dramatic
examples, Mizoguchi and Ozu,
who are often thought to be
his superior, even greater
directors than Kurosawa.
This is a debate of nuances.
All three of these
directors are major artists.
But it is true, I think,
and it is widely recognized
that Kurosawa was the director
who crossed that barrier more
immediately, more
dramatically than any other,
and opened the world, not
just to Japanese cinema,
in some degree, but opened
the world in some longer
sense to Asian cinema
more generally,
that the so-called
Western world,
the European and
American cinema universes
had been fairly
oblivious to Asian cinema
and certainly to Japanese
cinema prior to this.
And the appearance of Rashomon,
its enormous impact in 1951,
began to change that.
So that what was demonstrated
in moment when Rashomon
won this reward, won The
Golden Lion at the Venice Film
Festival, was a
reinforcement of a principle
I've been discussing throughout
the semester, the notion
of film as an international
medium, the notion
that directors from
different national cinemas
were now being deeply
influenced by directors
from other nations,
and that film itself
was in some deep way, a
global phenomenon, even
an international form.
And I think it was in
the '50s and early '60s
that this idea began to
become more widely embraced
by film goers in the United
States and in Europe,
but perhaps especially
in the United States.
And one mark of
this, the emergence
of cinema as a fully recognized
independent art form.
Obviously people
had thought this,
and many directors had
achieved artistic distinction
before this.
But I'm talking about the
public understanding of movies,
the way people in different
cultures actually recognized
and thought about movies.
It was as if this is the moment
in which movies were understood
to enter the museum
in a certain way,
to earn in a public
sense, the status
that more traditional
art forms had had.
And one of the explanations for
why this would have been so,
why it would have had such
a powerful impact-- now,
I think I mentioned last
time that this insight was
partial in the United
States-- especially,
that is to say, in the
'50s and early '60s,
it began to dawn on movie
critics and scholars
of whom there were only a few
at that time and then movie
audiences that European films
and Asian films, especially
Japanese films, might
have great artistic value.
But it was a longer
time before Americans
began to realize that their
own native forms of films
had had a similar
kind of authority.
So this moment, in
the early 1950s,
was a deeply significant one.
Let's remember historically
what it represented in Europe
and in the United States.
It's the moment of the emergence
of Italian neorealism, which
itself begins to establish a
kind of very powerful claim
on people's attention.
One irony of
Rashomon's success was
that it was not very
successful in Japan
when it was released in 1950.
And the producer, the
production company
responsible for the film was
very dubious about entering it
in the competition, didn't think
it was a significant film, even
though it transformed
Kurosawa's career
because of the immense
recognition it finally got.
And Kurosawa
himself recognized--
he'd been making films for
almost a decade before that,
but Rashomon was his most
ambitious film to that point,
and it also incorporated
more innovative strategy,
visual strategies than
any he had tried before.
It established him as an
international director.
And I mentioned the names
of two other directors
just from different
traditions as a way
of reminding you of another
feature of this phenomenon,
another reason, as I
began to say earlier,
for why this moment was
such a significant one.
And the term I use here is
modernism, modernist cinema.
Remember, one of the ways
to understand this idea
is to recognize that a
great revolution in the arts
had occurred at the turn
of the 20th century,
the end of the 19th, and at
the turn of the 20th century.
We've talked about this earlier.
It's the movement
we call modernism.
It's the moment of Picasso.
It's the moment of
James Joyce, and it
was a kind of revolution in
both visual art, literature,
music took place in this period.
And among the characteristics
of this modernist
movement was a newly complicated
and self-conscious attitude
toward narrative itself,
toward storytelling.
So modernism in literature
and in art involved,
among other things if not
a hostility or antagonism,
at least a kind of
skepticism about
inherited traditional categories
and ways of doing things.
And one form this
took in narrative
was to dislocate or
disorient the narrative line.
Instead of telling a story
in a chronological sequence,
a lot of the great works of
fiction of the modernist era,
books by writers like
Joseph Conrad, or Proust,
the great French
novelist who was so
preoccupied by memory
and human subjectivity,
or the great German
novelist, Thomas Mann,
a number of other great
figures that we could mention
began to construct stories in
which chronological order was
profoundly disrupted.
And they also began to
create stories in which there
were multiple narrators.
And the effect of
multiple narrators
begins-- even if you do
nothing more than have
multiple narrators, you
begin to raise questions
about the veracity,
the truthfulness
of any single perspective.
And you will understand
when you look at Rashomon
why this movie embodies
many of these same modernist
principles.
But the point is that
cinema, as a narrative form,
lag behind these more
traditional arts.
And it really wasn't
until the 1950s,
and partly because of
films like Rashomon,
that it began to be
recognized that the movies too
could embrace and embody
the principles of modernism.
So one way to understand
what happened in the 1950s
is to recognize that directors
like Kurosawa and Ingmar
Bergman, the great
Swedish director,
and Fellini, the great
Italian director,
and the inheritor and expander
of the neorealist tradition,
going far beyond
a narrow realism,
that directors like that
began to create films
that in a formal sense,
in a structural sense,
and also in terms
of their content
had the kind of complexity,
nuance, and skepticism,
and even the philosophic
self-awareness
that was characteristic
of high modernism
at the turn of the 20th century.
So it's as if what was
going on was the movies
themselves were now asserting
themselves as a modernist art.
I don't mean as a
contemporary art.
I'm referring specifically
to the modernist movement,
and to the dislocated,
and much more demanding
kinds of narrative
strategies that
are characteristic of
the modernist movement.
So Rashomon played
a fundamental role
in this sort of
transformation of what
we might call the cultural
understanding of movies
among ordinary people, as well
as among scholars, critics,
and other filmmakers.
I want to mention
one other point.
I'll give you a kind
of note to clarify
some of what I've
been implying, some
of what I implied when I
talked about Mizoguchi and Ozu
as directors who were
often even more highly
regarded than Kurosawa.
I'll leave that to each
individual film goer.
All three directors are
astonishing and remarkable.
But it wouldn't be
appropriate to talk, even
about this single
film, Rashomon,
without paying respects to
those two great directors whose
dates I've put on your outline.
I won't talk about individual
films by these directors,
but I urge you all to look
them up, read about them
in David Cook's history
of narrative film,
and think about
experimenting by extending
your knowledge of
Japanese cinema
by trying films by these
two remarkable directors.
One of the things that's
characteristic of all three
of these directors, of
Kurosawa, even more fully
of Mizoguchi and Ozu, Ozu
most fundamentally of all,
is that their films are
marked by a kind of impulse
toward stylization, toward
fabular, fable-like equations
that distinguish
them in some ways
from Western, from European,
and American films.
And I think that one
explanation for this
has to do with the longer
artistic traditions
of Japanese society.
Japanese film grows out
of theatrical traditions,
like kabuki theater,
or Noh drama,
N-O-H drama, both of which have
profoundly stylized and fable
like qualities.
They're anti-narrative,
in some sense,
and any of you who have ever
had even a minimal experience
with either of these two
theatrical traditions
will understand
what I'm discussing.
These are theaters of
gesture and of very decisive,
symbolic representation.
What we would think of as
sort of realistic characters
or realistic stories
are not a part
of these very
ancient traditions.
These theatrical traditions
go back hundreds, even
thousands of years.
So there's a tradition in
Japan of a kind of stylized,
of symbolic representation.
And you'll see, I
think, how in Russia,
how powerfully this principle
operates in Rashomon.
Even when film itself emerged
in Japan in the silent era,
it emerged in a
slightly different way.
And one of the most interesting
features of silent film
tradition in Japan was the
appearance of a character who
has no counterpart
in Western cinema,
a character called a
benshi, B-E-N-S-H-I.
Any of you heard of it?
None.
Well, he essentially was
a narrator and explainer,
and he stood next to the movies
in a way and gave explanations.
He said now, we will
introduce the villain.
Now, we will introduce-- he was
like a kind of intermediary,
a narrator or a
concierge who mediated
between the audience and the
text, who gave the audience
information.
Again in one sense,
we might think of it
as an anti-narrative tradition,
as a tradition in which things
are presented or spoken rather
than literally acted out,
and certainly one in which
the details of a story
are less important than
its general outline.
So when we talk
about stylization,
one of the things
we're talking about
is an impulse
toward what we might
think of as generalized argument
instead of specific argument,
an impulse to have one
moment stand symbolically
for many other
moments, and what we
might think of as
a simplification
or a distillation of reality
into certain symbolic moments
that are thought to be
emblematic in certain ways,
but don't necessarily
have a realistic feel.
And you'll see almost instantly
when this film begins,
there's a kind of prologue.
And then when the film
makes a transition
into the first sequence that
takes place in the forest,
you'll begin to see what I mean
when I say that the film seems
to enter into a kind
of symbolic realm
in which your sense of reality
is in some sense undermined,
as if you're entering into
a dream or a symbolic space.
Kurosawa, talking about
that astonishing sequence
at the beginning
of Rashomon, said
that camera's complex
movements and the movements
of a character
himself-- everything
is in motion in that
remarkable opening sequence.
Some people have called it the
most visually poetic sequence
in the history of movies.
Kurosawa called
this moment a moment
in which the camera was shown
to be penetrating into a space
where the heart loses its
way, as if you're penetrating
into an ancestral space,
into a space that's
dreamlike in fundamental ways.
So the very opening
of the film, or almost
the very opening of
the film establishes
this kind of complexity.
I don't want to exactly
call it an ambiguity,
but this complexity about
the nature of the reality
that you're watching.
And this is even before
the film proceeds
to present essentially
four different accounts
of the same event, these
conflicting with each
other in a variety of ways.
So these abstracting,
or symbolizing,
or stylizing narrative
and dramatic traditions
lie behind and shape the
movies in Japan, even movies
like Kurosawa's, which
embrace the camera's freedom
in a way that's much
more characteristic
of Western directors
than of Eastern ones.
Ozu, the second of
the two directors
I've listed on your
outline, is especially
famous for holding his
camera almost stationary
for a tremendously long time.
And in fact, he's
sometimes called a director
who tries to create
a zen aesthetic,
because the camera is so
quiet, and so stationary,
and relatively inactive.
It's a style that lays
tremendous emphasis
on the nuances of facial
expression and vocal tone.
And both Mizoguchi and
Ozu do, in some sense,
have an even greater
sense of stylization
in many of their films
than Kurosawa does.
But I don't want
to oversimplify,
because they are also capable of
very great, realistic moments,
and they have a
moral realism that's
at least as powerful in their
films as Kurosawa himself.
Kurosawa's career is
a very remarkable one.
And I wish I had time to
talk about it in detail.
Organizational structure
of Japanese cinema
was not unlike the
structures that
developed in Western
societies in the United States
or in France.
There were
essentially monopolies
of not a small number, but
a relatively larger number
of film production companies
operating at different levels
of significance.
So they were second
rate, and then they
were second level and third
level production companies,
as well.
But all of them operated
in a similar way.
The director was a more
dominant than major figure
in this system, and
surrounding each director
were a group of workers and
a group of creative people,
including usually performers who
went with a director from film
to film, as well as
his technical people.
They would often use the same
people to write their music,
and the same crew to work on the
film-- if they could succeed,
get the same cinematographer.
And Kurosawa's-- so Kurosawa's
group was called the Kurosawa
gumi, G-U-M-I. It means
the group, or cadre.
The Kurosawa group worked
on a series of films.
I don't mean it was
always identical.
There were changes, but
it was a stable group
unified especially by Kurosawa's
vision and supervision.
And I've listed here a few of
his most famous and fundamental
films besides Rashomon.
Ikiru, maybe his greatest
film, a realistic film
set in the modern world.
The title means
to live, and it's
about a man who discovers
that he has only a few months
to live.
And it stars the
actor Takashi Shimura,
who plays the
woodcutter in Rashomon.
The other actor that
you'll see in Rashomon
that is one of
Kurosawa's favorites
and appears again and
again in Kurosawa's films
is the actor Toshiro Mifuni.
Rashomon, he plays the bandit.
You'll see what a
remarkable figure he is.
So I've only listed a
few of his films here,
but among his most
important, Rashomon, Ikiru,
Seven Samurai--
many people would
say the greatest of
all samurai movies,
and probably the greatest
of all Western movies,
because it puts most
American Westerns to shame.
It's influenced by
American Westerns,
as Kurosawa himself
acknowledged.
And it was itself, that
film, made in 1954,
remade as an American film some
years later under the title,
The Magnificent Seven.
And it was so
successful that a sequel
was made, something like The
Magnificent Seven Return.
And in fact, one of the deep
features of Kurosawa's work
is that many of
his films have been
remade by other
directors, both American
and European directors.
Rashomon was made
14 years later,
remade 14 years later, with
Kurosawa given screenplay
credit in a film directed
by Martin Ritt in the United
States called The Outrage.
And it retells the story that's
at the heart of Kurosawa's
film.
It starred Paul Newman among
others, and Edward G. Robinson,
among other significant
American actors.
Throne of Blood I mentioned,
because many people see it
as the most successful of all
adaptations of Shakespeare.
It's a Japanese kabuki-ized
version of Macbeth starring
Toshiro Mifune.
And many people think
of it as the greatest
of all Shakespearean
adaptations.
Yojimbo is a samurai film,
a much more straightforward
samurai film in many
ways than Seven Samurai,
also stars Mifune, and it has
brilliant, brilliant sword
fight sequences in it that
anticipate the kind of thing
that is now common in Asian
cinema, but much less trivially
done in Kurosawa's than in
many of these later films that
merely seem to want to
entertain us by their sword
play and the physical
grace of their actors,
but don't connect
nearly so powerfully
as Kurosawa's films do to a
profound and serious historical
setting and story.
Yojimbo was also made into an
American movie called Last Man
Standing, in 1966.
I mentioned Kagemusha, only
because it's a later film,
and many people
admire it, because it
shows that Kurosawa was working
effectively, even in old age.
He made another film in
1985, one of his final films
called Ran, R-A-N, which
is a remake of King Lear.
And these two older films,
later films, Kagamusha and Ran,
show Kurosawa's visual sense,
visual imagination to great
effect, but they feel
stylized in the way that
they're-- stylized may
not be the right word.
They feel abstract in a way
that earlier, Kurosawa's films
do not.
They are extraordinary
spectacles,
but they don't have the
same interest in character,
the same focus on
character that his earlier
films, despite their
stylisation, seem to do.
I've saved most of my time to
talk about Rashomon itself,
because it's such a central
and significant film.
And I hope when you watch
it, you'll not be impatient,
and especially that
you watch for the ways
in which from
sequence to sequence,
the visual style alters.
It's a very demanding
film, in that sense.
Let's begin by talking a little
bit about the problem of rape
in cultural stories,
because I think
that one of the problems with
responding fully to Rashomon
is that we, especially
in the Western world,
are newly struggling with
notions of gender identity
and of the legacy
of patriarchy that
put us in a fraught and
complex position in relation
to stories like
that of this film.
And I want to confront it
right in the beginning.
As some of you may know,
the story of Rashomon
is the story of a rape.
There are four
different-- a rape occurs
at the center of
the film, and there
are four different
accounts of what happened,
of how the rape occurred.
And the film is
partly a meditation
on what motives do the
different tellers have
for putting this particular
spin on the story?
And part of what's subtle and
disturbing about the movie
is that when the first
testimony is given,
it's not fully clear
yet to us that we should
be skeptical of the testimony.
And I think the first time-- one
of the people whose testimony
we heard is the
murderer himself,
or the rapist himself,
the Mifune character.
He's the first one to testify.
And as he's
testifying, it begins
to dawn on an attentive viewer
that maybe his testimony
is self-serving in
certain ways, that there's
certain things he's saying
that maybe we shouldn't fully
accept.
And then, when the next account
comes, our sense of skepticism
is reinforced and fortified.
We begin to worry.
And then the film itself
reminds us of the fact
that these tales are
problematic, because the film's
structure is so interesting.
Roughly every 10
minutes or so, I've
timed most of them-- a
little less than 10 minutes
in some cases, a little
longer than some--
you'll have an extended
narrative sequence which
will last about 10 minutes.
Usually it's the
testimony of one
of the people appearing
before the court.
And then after that
happens, the film sort of
shifts into another mode.
And the way you can tell
is that it shifts back
to the scene with
which the film opens.
All the way through the
scene, it's marked by this.
The structure of
the film is marked
by this return to a
scene at Rashomon gate,
which I'll explain in a moment.
So one point that I'm
trying to get to here
is the idea that as
we watched the film
and we begin to weigh the
accounts that different people
give of this rape,
many of us are
likely to feel
uneasy and disturbed,
because one of the things
that disturbs me in the film
is the woman's
reaction to her rape.
She feels terrible shame.
It's as if she felt--
and there seems
to be an impulse in the film
that certainly some people have
certainly gotten there.
At least they
perceive an impulse
in the film or an impulse in the
narrative to blame the victim.
In some sense,
what I'm suggesting
is not that that response
is inappropriate,
but that it's a little bit off
key, off center, because if you
recall the idea that the
film is deeply stylized,
and it's set in an ancestral
past, in a medieval Japan,
in a moment of terrible
social breakdown in which
vestigial or ancestral attitudes
towards sexuality and gender
are being mobilized or awakened.
And if we understand
it in that way,
we can begin to recognize
that our own discomfort
with the subject matter is a
discomfort that the film itself
may even be aware of and
may even be encouraging.
And as you're watching the
film, watch how, in some sense,
especially in one moment
where the victim of rape
makes an appeal to
her husband right
after-- there's a
sequence where we
see her embracing her husband
and looking into his face.
Now the problem is she's
giving this testimony,
and there's some reason.
It's after the fact,
and there's some reason
to doubt what she's saying,
especially as the film goes on.
Nonetheless, it's a
moment of great power.
And that moment at least
mobilizes a sympathy
for the victim of rape.
That is very significant,
because you hear so little
of it elsewhere in the film.
Not that the woman
is treated badly,
but she's subjected
to the same suspicions
as the other central characters.
But there's a larger
thing to think about,
a larger way in which we
can accommodate ourselves
to the slight
discomfort we might feel
at turning a story of rape
into a philosophic discourse
as this film does.
And here's how we might do that.
Let me just remind you
that stories about rape
are at the heart
of many cultures.
How many of you have
heard of the story
of The Rape of Europa?
It's a Greek myth.
None of you?
In many ways, it's the story
of the foundation of Europe.
Zeus disguised as a white
bull, the great Greek god,
the god of all gods.
One of Zeus's best habits or
the most remarkable habits
in these mythological
stories is that when
he gets a yen for
a human female,
he will disguise himself
as a creature of the earth
and go down and rape her.
And he does this with Europa.
The rape of Europa is a
kind of symbolic story
which later Europeans
actually took
as one of the founding tails of
how Europe itself was founded.
Can you think of another story
in which Zeus was a rapist?
How many of you know
the story of Leda
and the Swan, about which Yeats
wrote such beautiful poems?
Again, Zeus, the god of
gods, disguises himself
as a great spawn and swoops down
on lead of this beautiful woman
and rapes her in
the guise of a swan.
And there's a brilliant, almost
pornographically powerful poem
by W. B. Yeats in
which he describes
this terrible moment of rape.
It's one of the great
poems of the Western world,
and it's about this rape.
So what I'm reminding you
of is that the misogyny,
that you may sense there
is a misogyny that's
embedded in culture.
It's a misogyny that's
embedded in all the stories
that human beings tell,
in many of the stories
that human beings tell
themselves about the world,
about the relations
of men and women,
and often, especially about
the foundations of society,
so that this meditation
on human frailty
and human deceit focused on
a rape from that perspective
is one of many such stories.
Not a unique object at all.
And it seems to
me that that's one
of the ways in which we can
recognize that what Kurosawa
is doing is part of
a long, and complex,
and in many ways, very
disturbing habit of mind
that many, many cultures share.
The title-- Rashomon.
Western students are
often puzzled by it.
It's a reference to
the name of the gate,
but the word gate
is complicated too,
because it's not an
American gate that
just opens and closes.
It's a great, massive
entrance to the city of Kyoto
in the southern part of
Japan in the late 11th
or early 12th century.
It's a period of
complete disillusion
and destructive poverty,
political chaos.
And the broken down
condition of the gate,
which you get long shots of,
you see this massive structure.
There's a terrible
rainstorm going on,
under which certain people come
to get shelter from the rain.
And that is Rashomon gate.
And it's broken down
condition symbolizes
the broken down
condition politically
and socially of the society
that is represented there.
And again and again,
the characters
gathered beneath the gate
to protect themselves
from the weather and
gauge in conversation
about human nature.
Are human beings innately evil?
Do they always lie?
Can we never trust them?
And one of the characters
who carries on this discourse
is a priest who has an
idealizing tendency, which
another of the
character's a commoner.
He's called the commoner.
He's an ordinary man is
constantly mocking and arguing
against.
It's almost a kind
of argument that
reminds me in some ways of
the argument between spirit
and flesh in
Cervante's Don Quixote,
in which Sancho
Panza is constantly
reminding the idealizing
Quixote of the miserable
actuality of the world.
Look, when you get
stabbed, you bleed.
When you haven't
eaten, you're hungry.
The world is real in a way
and miserable in some respects
in a way that
idealists don't like.
And so that's a kind
of argument that
runs through these interludes
as the film goes on.
So the title refers
to the Rashomon Gate,
and Rashomon Gate is
itself a massive symbol
for the breakdown of order for
the miserable circumstances
that individuals
find themselves in.
And one of the things you'll
see is that it's chilly.
It's cold.
It's raining like mad,
a tremendous torrent,
a downpour incidentally
created partly by fire trucks.
In his autobiography,
Kurosawa talks
about how difficult
it was to create
this sense of an
immense ongoing,
almost a tsunami of
rain, and he talked
about the technical
difficulties of doing so.
Very impressive rain, the
most impressive rainstorm
in the history of
movies, I think.
So these people are gathered
beneath the gate in order
to protect themselves, and the
gate's symbolic significance
is important.
We will notice that
one of the things they
do when they get
cold is they go over
to certain parts
of the building.
It's a wooden structure already
half broken down and in decay.
And they'll break off banisters
or other pieces of wood,
and break them up,
and burn them up.
And the implication is if
things go on like this,
pretty soon the
whole gate will have
been consumed by people who have
tried to take shelter under it.
So it's a symbol of the
breakdown of social order
and of the society.
I've already
mentioned the medium.
The Japanese word is miko.
And I mentioned it
here, just because I
wanted to be sure
all of you understood
what was going on there.
The husband is dead when
the testimony begins.
He's a samurai who was the
husband of the rape victim.
And as the story unfolds,
you'll get the basic facts,
but even when the
film is over, there
are many fundamental things you
won't be able to have decided.
And I think that's certainly
part of Kurosawa's point.
So the medium is just this
clairvoyant type apparently
real characters believed in
and socially recognizable
in late medieval
Japan, a character
who claims to have
access to the words
and beliefs of dead people.
So the dead man testifies.
And another way of
reminding you that we're
looking at a very
stylised, a story that
isn't in a narrow
sense, realistic at all.
The visual style of
a film is especially
remarkable and
astounding, in some ways.
It's almost as if each form of
testimony has its own style.
And you might want to watch the
way in which Kurosawa builds
his eclectic and dynamic way
in which Kurosawa's editing
camerawork use of music
combine to a kind of almost
constant visual excitement.
One of the most remarkable
things about the film
is how many sequences in it are
without dialogue-- extended,
wordless sequences,
truly entirely cinematic.
The opening sequence--
almost the opening sequence--
the first extended
sequence in a forest, which
comes after the sort of
introduction, which I've
described earlier,
is a magnificently
clear example of that process.
And one of the things that you
may notice in that sequence
especially is the way in
which you become increasingly
disoriented about the direction
in which the woodcutter is
going.
He's apparently narrating the
story, and his narration sort
of segues into a
visual experience,
as happens again and
again in the film.
And the visual
experience we have
shows him going into the woods,
walking, and then discovering
first the woman's hat, and
then discovering other things,
and discovering a body, and
then running away in fear.
And as he penetrates
into the woods,
one of the things that happens
is the camera is always moving.
And the camera becomes as
interested in the forest
itself, in this
densely wooded forest
and in the play
of light and dark,
because the sunlight comes
through the wooded canopy
in odd and profoundly
visually powerful ways.
You begin to have a sense
that the camera is at least as
interested in the woods
and in the play of sunlight
as it is in the motions
of the woodcutter.
And the whole
sequence has a kind
of profoundly lyrical,
but also in some degree,
disorienting sense
that as Kurosawa said,
you're entering a space that's
dreamlike, that's dangerous,
a place where the heart will
lose its way, as if you're
entering a symbolic space,
not a realistic space--
a stylized space
in some deep way.
And there are a couple
of specific strategies
that Kurosawa uses in the
film to reinforce, I think,
our sense that he's
engaging every element
of his cinematic palate in
order to create his effects.
One thing he does, he violate
certain rules, especially
at the time where
it would have been
tremendously shocking to
professional directors.
One thing he does
in the film was he
points the camera at the sun,
and he creates sun effects.
That was a no-no.
It was a sort of a rule that
directors should never do that.
Kurosawa does it.
And you watch how he does it.
It's very powerful.
It also has a
disorienting effect,
the effect of making us
understand more deeply what
it's like to work our way
through the incredible dense
forest in which
the crime occurs,
as if the forest itself is
a space so complex and so
private, so cut off
from the outer world
that almost anything
could happen there--
a space of dream,
a space of terror,
a space of symbolic fable.
And there are a
couple of other things
I wanted to mention about
the way his camera behaved.
One is that Kurosawa uses here
a device at certain points
in the film, a very
interesting device.
The official name for it,
the fancy name for it,
the technical name for it is he
makes what is called an axial
cut, A-X-I-A-L. It's really
a form of a jump cut--
that is to say, an abrupt edit
which you're not fully prepared
for.
A jump card, as you
know, breaks the action
in mid-stride, or in
mid-action, and then jumps
to something else in
a way that's slightly
disorienting that eliminates.
It's elliptical.
It eliminates connection
or transitions.
But the axial cut does
this in a very dramatic way
that also calls attention to
the apparatus of the movies.
The most dramatic places in
which this occurs in the film
are certain scenes in which you
see the samurai husband tied
up, sitting on the
ground, tied up like this,
kneeling on the ground.
And the camera's at
some distance from him
and moved toward him, but
it doesn't move toward him
in a smooth trucking motion
characteristic of most films.
What it does is
it moves forward,
and it stops, and then it jumps.
It moves forward.
And what you feel
is it leaps forward.
And what's happening,
of course, is
that he stops the
cameras forward movement,
moves it further, makes a cut.
So the effect is
the camera moves--
not that the camera's
jerky, but it's
as if it's speeded
up in some sense.
We can feel that the camera
is becoming elliptical.
So say this fellow in the front
is the person I'm focusing on.
I'll be here.
You'll see this shot.
And then you'll see this shot,
and the effect is very abrupt.
Watch how it happens.
One effect, one consequence
of this kind of a shot
is that watching it, you can
feel how mechanical it is.
You begin to think
to yourself well,
how could that
have been created?
You're aware of its
mechanical qualities.
That is to say, you
become partly aware
of the apparatus behind
the making of the movie.
It's a moment of
self-consciousness
that other elements on
the film also reinforce.
So the visual
style is profoundly
eclectic and dynamic.
I've mentioned the axial code in
pointing the camera at the sun.
Maybe I'll mention
one other device.
One of the other technically
intricate, and at the time,
revolutionary thing
that Kurosawa did was he
violates what's called
the 180 degree rule.
And the 180 degree
rule essentially
has to do with your sense
of spatial orientation
within the frame.
Essentially the 180
degree rule holds
that if you're showing
characters moving
in this direction, so you're
showing a character moving
this way, you won't
suddenly, if you're still
going in the same direction,
show him walking this way,
because it disorients
the viewer.
In our film, in Rashomon,
there are certain moments.
There are hints of it in
that opening sequence,
that lyrical, first
sequence in the forest
that I mentioned in which
you can see that the camera's
own movements complicate,
and in some sense,
confuse our sense of where
the woodcutter is going.
And it's in that sequence and
some other places in the film
as well, where the 180
degree rule is violated.
And the effect again is to
disorient us, is to feel gee,
I don't know whether
I'm coming or going.
This guy doesn't know
whether he's coming or going.
What kind of a space is he in?
Again, violating certain
conventions of traditional
filmmaking in order
to create new effect.
And the consequence
of these choices,
the impact of these
choices in 1951,
when the film won its
prize, was profound.
I want to say one other thing,
another aspect of the film's
structure, which I've
described him perfectly.
And I apologize for being
so tongue tied about it.
But as I tried to
describe earlier,
the basic structure of the
film becomes fairly clear.
What happens is
you get testimony.
Then there are interruptions
in which you-- essentially, all
four of the primary
pieces of testimony
takes place in the past.
So what we have are flashbacks,
but competing flashbacks.
And at various points, the film
returns to our scene of reign
at Rashomon Gate
in which the people
under the gate, the three people
under the gate-- two of them
are actually partial
participants.
The third, the
commoner, is just a kind
of listener to the story,
although a profound commutator
on it.
The Sancho Panza
type who says, look.
The world is miserable.
Why should you believe anyone?
And the priest is
constantly resisting him.
Well when we return
to these moments--
so we return to Rashomon
Gate several times,
many times in the film.
And every time we return
to that spot, where are we?
We're in the present
time of the film.
So one of the things
the film does,
it creates what I call
a drama of the telling
of the story in which the
conversation that's going on
underneath Rashomon Gate
is a kind of metacommentary
on the story that
we're watching.
The characters inside
the film comment on well,
can we believe her?
Is this credible?
Why did she say this?
And the effect of
this metacommentary
is to create essentially
a separate story.
What's the separate story?
It's a philosophic topic.
The topic is the
telling of stories.
In other words,
this interruption
creates a new kind of moral
and thematic complexity
in the film, something
that's characteristic
of the great novels
and fiction works
I mentioned earlier
in the lecture that
appeared at the turn
of the 20th century.
Not is the principle of
unreliable narration being
introduced, and the principle
of competing flashbacks being
of dislocated chronology being
introduced-- all of those
things are operating.
But what is even more
important about it
is that these moments
of conversation
amongst those three
characters at Rashomon Gate
also constitute a kind
of philosophic meditation
on the nature of storytelling
and the nature of truth.
And they actually say oh,
how can you believe a person?
Or what is truth?
How can we believe
what anybody says?
So the film calls
attention not only
to the profound subjectivity
of human responses
and the profoundly
unreliable nature of memory,
but also the extent to
which individuals themselves
have reasons developing
from their egos
to distort and tell
stories that are more
flattering to themselves
and so that by the time
we come to the end of the film,
it isn't clear at all, when
the film is over, whether
there is a truth, whether there
is any final truth
that we can embrace.
The issues are not
finally resolved.
But what is resolved for us is
the idea that human reality is
immensely complex,
that human beings
are endlessly deceitful,
that the stories
they tell about themselves and
others may not be trustworthy.
So in other words,
the film opens out
into a kind of
philosophic profundity
that's partly a function
of its structure.
So it's another example, one
of the most remarkable examples
that we've seen in our course,
of what I call organic form,
of a text whose structure helps
us understand what it's about
and whose structure is
part of what it means,
whose structure is
essential to its meaning.
We couldn't imagine this
film as a straightforward,
chronological sequence.
It wouldn't be able
to do what it does.
So what I mean by the drama
of the telling of the story
is literally that.
That is to say,
there's a second story,
a second subject matter
in these interludes--
let's call them interludes in
these interruptions in which we
return to the present
time, get out of the past.
And those interludes are an
extended, philosophic, and
moral conversation
about human nature,
about the nature of
our human capacity
to understand the
world, and our capacity
to talk about it, to narrate
it accurately and fully.
So this drama of the telling
of the story, this drama
of the screening, this drama
of the making of the story
is as important a dimension of
the film as its actual story,
as the actual story
that it wants to tell.
I have two other points to make
about this remarkable film,
and I'll be done.
The first is that one of the
things I think you'll notice,
as the story goes on, and
as different people give
different accounts
of what happened
is that the actual physical
conflict between the two
male characters, which one would
expect to be grand and heroic,
is almost always
clownish and unheroic.
We expect this great-- he's
a samurai warrior, after all,
and the man he's
doing battle with
is a very famous or infamous
bandit, criminal-- so
gifted a criminal
that he's famous.
And one realizes in
retrospect that when
the criminal, the Toshiro Mifune
character, gives his testimony.
In the beginning, in the
early part of the film,
he's exaggerating his
own martial genius.
Although we don't fully
realize that at first,
but it becomes clearer
and clearer to us
as the film goes on
that he has a motive
to exaggerate his heroic
stature, and his strength,
and so forth.
Not to mention, a motive
to exaggerate and maybe
to lie about the
woman's reaction
to his forced attentions.
So all of that is an essential
part of our understanding
of what is at
stake, I guess, when
we think about the
various subject
that Rashomon gestures toward.
So the clownish, unheroic
behavior of these fighters
is something to
note, because there's
a deep skepticism
in the film itself
about all forms of
human aggrandizement.
There's a skepticism that the
film shares with the commoner
who maybe is too negative
about human nature, who thinks
human beings are
completely abject,
and that this is the
justification for the most
selfish kind of behavior,
because no one can behave well.
I have hardly
exhausted the film,
but I hope I've said
some things that
will be valuable and useful
to you on your first viewing.
But let me end by talking about
the ending, because the ending
of Rashomon presents us with a
problem similar to the problem
that we confronted in a film
like The Last Laugh, Der Letzte
Mann, in which there
seems to be a kind
of optimistic or reassuring
ending to this film.
The film has been
very dark and rainy.
And in fact, one
of the ways you can
tell that the film
has changed registers
is that the rain
finally disappears.
Well as you're watching
the ending, which
is quite explicit, even heavy
handed about its attempt
to return us to a sort of
more hopeful view of mankind,
you should ask yourself, does
it deserve to be deleted?
All through the '40s,
when Kurosawa was first
learning his trade, he began
to direct early in the '40s.
And this film in 1950 is
his first real masterwork.
He's become more and more
confident and ambitious
as a director
during this period,
but he hadn't displayed his
full capacities as a director
until this point, most
accounts of his career suggest.
But during this
period, in the 1940s,
Kurosawa took up
part of himself what
he regarded as a
social project, which
was to try to help renovate
Japan after the devastations
of the war.
And his films of the
'40s almost always
try to suggest various
forms various ways
in which people could behave
decently and heroically--
if not heroically, at
least decently in an effort
to renovate and
reconstitute a damaged
society, a broken society.
One of the reasons that the
breakdown of ancient Japan
is so powerful in
Rashomon, no question,
is that Kurosawa and his cast
believed that in some sense,
there was a symbolic analogy
to be made between conditions
in Japan, actual Japan in
the 1940s and early '50s,
and the broken, terrifying
conditions of society
in the 11th and 12th
centuries in the past parable
that the narrative
is telling us.
And this film continues
that tradition.
But I think many, many
viewers, I among them,
have the feeling that this
is more wish fulfillment
on Kurosawa's part than reality.
And one could say from an
artistic standpoint then,
one might conclude that
it's a weakness in the film.
I think I might say
that the film might
be more powerful, more
truthful to itself,
that the ending that's tacked
on may undermine its deepest
energies in disturbing ways.
So it's another example in
which commercial and social
imperatives may be interfering
with the artistic integrity
of the text.
But it's significant,
important to understand
that this was a tendency that
was present in Kurosawa's
work all the way
through the '40s,
and that therefore, it's a kind
of expression of a moral sense
that the director
had that begins
to become less powerful
after Rashomon,
although he remains a
deeply moral director.
So the ending is a
question, and you
might want to ask yourself
how you would respond
to the question of the relevance
of the ending to the rest
to the rest of the film.
Let me end with a reminder about
maybe what is, in some ways,
the most powerful
aspect of what happens
when you're watching Rashomon.
I've said that you
feel that you've
entered into if not a dream,
into a kind of uniquely
stylized space in
which what happens
resembles what
happens in real life,
but also distills what
highlights it in a way that
isn't true of actuality.
And I think you feel
this mythic tendency
all the way through the film.
In a certain sense, one way
of capturing what I'm saying
is to say that
there is a tension
in the film between this
impulse to be mythic,
to tell a story
that it understands
to have a fable-like
significance and its sense
of the complexity and
concreteness of actuality.
That is to say, so there's this
wonderful, constant tension
in the film between the
enormous persuasiveness
of the individual
images that you see.
But you sense also that
you're in a world that's
not totally real.
So the tension I'm trying
to get you to feel,
you can feel it in the dialogue.
But especially you can feel
it in the visual images,
in the visual
texture of the film.
You can feel a kind of
tension between an impulse
to mythologize,
and to fable-ize,
and an impulse to show the
world in its deepest and most
concrete elements, in its
most authentic actuality.
And the tension between the
two-- gee, this is so real.
Gee, this is so unreal.
This is so fable-like, is part
of the secret of the movie.
And one way you can feel it
with an immensely intense power
is sometimes when you
see the way the film
deals with human flesh,
there are certain scenes,
for example, where a woman's
hand will be on a man's body--
talk about how you can be
erotic without offending anyone.
There's a moment where you
can see the woman's fingers
pressing into the man's flesh.
It's an immensely erotic and
powerfully concretizing moment.
It reminds you of flesh.
It reminds you of film's
power to capture actuality
with a vividness that goes far
beyond what words can ever do,
the visual power of movie.
And that's what I mean
when I say that there's
this constant tension in the
film between the mythologizing
tendencies of the story, and
of Kurosawa's imagination,
and what we might call
the breaking tendency,
the concretizing tendency
of the film medium,
which has this
capacity to register
the gross, concrete
reality of our experiences
with a detail and a power
that no other medium can.
Now this sense of tension
between a story that
wants to be a fable and a story
that wants to persuade you
of its concrete
reality is part of what
makes the film so memorable
and so significant.